un caso que muestra al parlamento
australiano como un lugar inseguro para
las mujeres la senadora independiente
lidiator denunció que fue acusada
sexualmente dentro del legislativo del
país
experimenté comentarios sexuales y
hombres poderosos me propusieron cosas
inapropiadamente
un hombre me siguió y me acorraló en una
escalera y la mayor parte de esto fue
presenciado por el personal y los
compañeros del parlamento
nadie fue testigo de lo que sucedió en
la escalera ya que no hay cámaras en la
escalera la senadora no identificó a la
persona responsable en el discurso ante
el parlamento sin embargo thorp afirmó
un día antes que el senador del partido
liberal David acoso y agredió
sexualmente aunque las acusaciones y la
retiró Poco después el legislador fue
expulsado el parlamento
se reuní con el senador van esta mañana
y hace poco le informé al senador van de
mi decisión
un informe de la comisión de Derechos
Humanos publicado en 2021
mostró que un tercio de los empleados
del parlamento federal de Australia ha
sido acusado sexualmente el 63% de las
parlamentarias Ha experimentado acoso
sexual la situación también es sensible
para las personas pertenecientes a la
comunidad lgbtiq más el 53% experimentó
acoso En comparación con el 31% de las
personas que se identifican como
heterosexuales Aunque la senadora
decidió no emprender acciones legales
sobre el asunto su caso vuelve a poner
la lupa sobre el parlamento australiano